your faces are just lit up with radiance
a newlywed glow is so real talk to me
about life you know a couple months into
marriage the best ever why is it so
great just something actually change I
know this a lot of people argue it's a
piece of paper did things change when
you actually get married is the love
deeper I feel that it is I know some
people say it shouldn't change it should
be the same you love you know but for me
it did I'm just so happy to come home to
him every day he's my dream guy you feel
the same way I know you're trying to
make a joke right now but you can't
think of one can you try to mess with me
how correct I should be right yeah
no it's great it's great I think it's
just you just learn to be better
together yeah and and that's the joy
that it is and we're lucky that we both
share the same loves for animals and all
that's kind of what brought us together
in the first place
so it's a we have a lot of common has
there been a highlight has there been a
moment something like oh my god we are
totally married like at this point
probably the rabbit when I woke up and
said I woke up one morning a nice what
did I say you had a couple moments with
a rabbit I think she wakes up I wanna I
wanna adopt a rabbit and by the end of
the day we had two white albino rabbits
we rescued but the point was I woke up
and said I wanted them and he goes let's
go and so we went and we have eight
rabbits now I have an illegal amount of
rabbits that I've rescued where are you
keeping all this support the other day
the other day she goes honey you kill
about pigs
and I said I just stopped it is it the
cook residence or the cook farm it is
panting the farm it's definitely
apartment yeah it's fantastic listen I
know the fur baby game is on lock
between the two of you you've told us
you're really not in a rush to have kids
do you have the baby edge
I'm ready where we are listen you're a
fierce businesswoman you're an
incredible actress what is the number
one lesson that you want to instill in
your children one day is it animal
rights what is it I definitely think
it's animal rights you know and also
being like you said being a
businesswoman I think you need to be
independent you need to have your own
life in your own situation and then
whoever comes into it makes it even more
magical because treating humans with
respect to any animals with respect it
says a lot about you and it starts at a
very very young age
kaley cuoco loving wife respected
actress and loyal animal rights
advocates the blonde beauty stepped out
to host the annual stand up for Pitts
benefit a cause extremely close to her
heart you're here every single year to
host stand up for hits why is it
important to you you know I obviously
love the breed I love all animals
everyone knows that about me this became
very important to me many many years ago
I have pips Peck cripples for the last
ten years and I've just realized they're
so they are looked at in such a way that
I just completely disagree with and I've
wanted to be their voice and this event
is at least opening people's minds and
I'm always proud to be part of it I know
the animals have changed your life but
tell me how what kind of an impact have
your rescues had on your life I
I'm not the person that invented this
statement but I always say who rescued
who I mean if you adopt an animal it's
gonna change your life no matter what
you bring into your home any four-legged
creature they are so grateful they're so
they love you to them I mean no matter
what you do no matter how you look
they're always there for you and I can't
imagine my life without my animals
filling my house
[Music]